I played a lot of Poker since I was a
kid so so the game was not new to me the
hands we are playing are insane you know
so if you're a poker player you'll go we
just wanted to make the the nature of
the betting uh believable but the hands
obviously had to be easily recognizable
for an audience that doesn't play poker
so they were quite crazy hands but uh
yeah everybody knew how to play poker
actually around that table except for
one Daniel he had no clue he sucked and
it was like it was the worst thing ever
that he of all people had to beat me and
win all my money it was like this is
wrong
well I got him back with the Rope so
that's good